the state of california just introduced
a brand new build to make bitcoin legal
tender now of course over the weekend as
this tweet started to go viral a lot of
people started to ask how do you make
bitcoin a decentralized digital currency
legal tender within a state without
having the national government sign off
on it as well well of course we started
to get more information what we saw was
that state politicians actually were the
ones who put forward this legislation
they're the ones who want to make
bitcoin legal tender what we have here
is a tweet from ian calderon who's a
state assembly member who said together
dennis porter and i are working on a
bipartisan effort to legislatively
explore bitcoin as legal tender in the
state of california more to come now i
started to go deep down the rabbit hole
i started to try to understand is this
actually real what are they talking
about well here's the senate bill itself
and what you can see is that in this
senate bill which was put forth on
february 18th of this year then all the
way down there at the bottom section one
says that they want to add to the
government code this is the change they
want to make a state agency may accept
cryptocurrency as a method of payment
for the provision of government services
that means that ultimately bitcoin would
be allowed to be accepted by those state
agencies by different departments or
groups and bitcoin would be recognized
as legal tender within the state now
this isn't the first state or government
around the world that's trying to make
this happen we know that el salvador
they already made bitcoin legal tender
last year and arizona recently
introduced a bill to make bitcoin legal
tender within their state as well but
there's also a number of countries
around the world where bitcoin is legal
for transactions france denmark germany
japan mexico spain united kingdom and
many more now the beauty of bitcoin is
it is decentralized nobody can stop you
from buying it selling it transacting in
a peer-to-peer way or simply holding it
bitcoin was built to be anti-censorship
and so ultimately we want to see
governments embracing it we want to see
them making it legal tender we want to
see it get much more beneficial tax
treatment but bitcoin is going to be
successful with or without the
government it's going to be successful
because ultimately people realize that
they want to hold a store value a medium
of exchange and a unit of account that
cannot be debased or devalued by anyone
else